una encuesta de opinión pública
investiga si la mayoría más del 50 por
ciento de los adultos apoya un
incremento de impuestos para ayudar a
financiar el sistema escolar local una
muestra aleatoria de 200 adultos mostró
que 113 de los muestreados apoyan el
incremento de impuestos los
investigadores usaron estos resultados
para probar la hipótesis nula de que la
proporción es 0.5 contra la hipótesis
alternativa que dice que es mayor a 0.5
donde p es la proporción verdadera de
los adultos que apoyan el incremento de
impuestos ellos calcularon un
estadístico de prueba de z
aproximadamente igual a 1 punto 84 y un
valor p correspondiente de
aproximadamente 0 punto 0 33 suponiendo
que se cumplen las condiciones de
inferencia cuál de las siguientes
opciones expresa una conclusión adecuada
aquí tenemos 4 conclusiones y pueden
pausar el vídeo en cualquier momento
para tratar de responder esto por su
cuenta vamos a resolverlos juntos
primero hay que asegurarnos de
comprender lo que nos dicen antes de ver
las respuestas tenemos esta población
tomamos una muestra el tamaño de la
muestra n es igual a 200 de esta muestra
calculamos la proporción muestral de los
adultos que apoyan el incremento de
impuestos que es de 113 que lo apoyan
entre 200 que es igual a 56.5 por ciento
el punto clave aquí es encontrar el
valor p cuál es la probabilidad de tener
un resultado igual o mayor a esta
cantidad de la proporción propuesta si
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera y si esa probabilidad o ese
valor p es menor que cierto valor que
hemos fijado de antemano conocido como
nivel de significancia que aún no nos
indican cuál es y qué me parece nos irán
en las opciones entonces rechazamos la
hipótesis nula y sospechamos la validez
de la hipótesis alternativa si el valor
p no es menor que alfa entonces no
rechazamos la hipótesis nula para
calcular esta probabilidad o este valor
p tenemos que determinar en cuántas
desviaciones estándar por arriba de la
media de la distribución muestral y
recordemos que la media de la
distribución muestral será la proporción
de la población que nosotros suponemos
cuántas desviaciones estándar por arriba
de esta media se encuentra esto de aquí
esto es lo que este estadístico
significa vamos a buscar esto en una
tabla z para conocer el área bajo la
curva normal que se encuentra más
alejada de al menos 1 punto 84 o más
desviaciones estándar por arriba de la
media y aquí nos dan ese valor así que
lo que vamos a hacer es comparar este
valor p con el nivel de significancia
que nos indican acá si el valor p es
menor que el nivel de significancia
entonces rechazamos la hipótesis nula y
con esto sospechamos la validez de la
hipótesis alternativa si esto no se
cumple entonces no rechazamos la
hipótesis nula veamos las opciones y si
no lo hicieron antes los invitó de nuevo
a que pause en el vídeo en el nivel de
significancia alfa igual a 0.01 ellos
deberían concluir que más del 50 por
ciento de los adultos apoyo en el
incremento de impuestos si alfa es una
centésima el valor p aquí es mayor a
tres centésimas es casi el 3.3 por
ciento en esta situación el valor p es
mayor o igual que alfa de hecho es mayor
que alfa
por lo que no concluimos que más del 50
por ciento de los adultos apoyan el
incremento de impuestos ya que nos
dijeron que la hipótesis nula es el 50%
y no estamos rechazando esto por lo que
esto no es verdadero en el nivel de
significancia alfa igual a 0.01 ellos
deberían concluir que menos del 50 por
ciento de los adultos apoyan el
incremento de impuestos esto tampoco es
verdadero porque no rechazamos la
hipótesis nula el que la proporción
verdadera es 50% en el nivel de
significancia alfa igual a 0.05 ellos
deberían concluir que más del 50 por
ciento de los adultos apoyan el
incremento de impuestos en efecto en
esta situación tenemos el valor p que es
0 punto 0 33 y es menor que el nivel de
significancia de 0.05 en cuyo caso
rechazamos la hipótesis nula y si
rechazamos la hipótesis nula
entonces sospechamos la validez de la
hipótesis alternativa la cual nos dice
que la proporción verdadera es mayor que
50% yo elijo esta opción en el nivel de
significancia alfa igual a 0.05 ellos
deberían concluir que menos del 50 por
ciento de los adultos apoyan el
incremento de impuestos esto
definitivamente no es verdadero si
rechazamos la hipótesis nula
entonces sospecharemos la validez de la
alternativa
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo